[музика]
так на початку навчального року виглядає
рівняння для вчителя коли він Або вона
проходить у клас усі ці три чинники
спровокували в тій чи іншій мірі
обмеження доступу учнів і вчителів до
освітнього процесу а як наслідок втратив
навчальному часі з місця освітніх
навчальних програм уміннях і знаннях
учнів як вчитель виявити ці втрати як
визначити нульову точку від якої
розпочинати подальше навчання учнів
команда проекту супровід урядових реформ
в Україні зібрали вчителів та авторів
стандартів у навчальних програм щоб
розробили тести з української мови і
математики які допоможуть виявити чи
мають учні прогалини і у якій конкретно
темі діагностичні тести будуть доступні
на платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн
та дозволять вчителеві здійснити
моніторинг результатів навчання учнів
5-7 та 9 класу тести допоможуть
вчителеві з'ясувати як учні засвоїли
тему з попередніх двох років навчання та
виявити над якими потрібно додатково
попрацювати за підсумками тестування
вчитель отримає детальний звіт це
дозволить йому зрозуміти ситуацію і
загально по класу і для кожного учня
індивідуально звіти своїми результатами
отримає також Кожен учень А разом зі
звітом І перелік посилань на матеріали
які варто опрацювати отримавши звіт за
результатами тестування учнів класу
вчитель може більше ефективно спланувати
свою роботу Як з усім класом так і з
окремими учнями індивідуально
розробляючи тести Ми з колегами
намагалися взяти із програми
найважливішу тому завдання тесту
перевіряють знання з ключових тем а
також базові уміння і навички
тестування дає змогу учасникам не лише
продемонструвати знання і застосувати
набуті уміння і навички але і Зробити
висновки після тесту
проаналізувавши отриманий результат за
допомогою зворотнього зв'язку водночас
Ми намагалися зробити завдання цікавими
для учнів актуальними та оригінальними
Тому в них є Гаррі Поттер успіхи
українських команд на міжнародних
змаганнях народні джереліни та байктари
після того як вчитель попрацює з учнями
варто провести вторинна діагностування
яке покаже чи потрібно продовжувати
роботу з програми та серед якої групи
учнів
діагностичні тести розроблені таким
чином щоб досягнення у вивченні тем
можна було перевірити двічі на початку
року коли учні лише починають навчання і
за 2-3 місяці після того як опрацювали
додатково матеріал для подолання
виявлених програм
тестування - це не контрольна робота
тому його результат неоцінка в шкільному
журналі або щоденнику учня а лише звіт
доступ до цього звіту має лише сам
учасник та вчитель
діагностичні тести доступні для усіх
бажаючих на платформі всеукраїнської
школи онлайн у розділі курсами